los residentes apilan sacos de arena y
hacen cócteles molotov mientras se
preparan para defender su hogar están
cada vez más seguros de que la sureña
ciudad de odessa podría ser el próximo
objetivo de rusia
estoy aquí para proteger mi ciudad estoy
cocinando llenando sacos de arena
mi casa está allí hay que defenderla así
nos han educado al tomar el control de
la ciudad portuaria los rusos
bloquearían a los ucranianos de acceso a
las aguas pues ya perdieron el control
sobre la mayor parte de la costa de soft
hoy no hay combates en odessa pero hay
barcos militares cerca en el mar negro
suponemos que el enemigo se está
preparando eso es lo que pensamos
el enemigo está preparando una operación
de desembarco en nuestra ciudad aunque
topco cursos crisanto los bordes el
ataque podría venir desde el mar negro
pero también por tierra desde la cercana
ciudad de gerson o desde el cielo bonnie
se están preparando para bombardear o
deza odessa los rusos siempre han venido
a odessa y han recibido una cálida
bienvenida y ahora que bombas cayendo
sobre o de esa artillería contra odessa
y los disparados contra la dehesa será
un crimen de guerra será un crimen
histórico el alcalde de odessa pide una
zona de exclusión aérea para proteger a
los cerca del millón de residentes que
viven en la ciudad la otan dice que esa
opción está fuera de la mesa